quelque chose qui est lui aussi très
cher mais dont on se doit de parler
c'est la mode automne hiver 84,85
troisième jour de nos défilés il y en
aura encore un
demain ce n'est pas terminé aujourd'hui
france comment résister au froid mais au
très grand froid
ah oui c'est la mode divers mais de très
très grands hivers et vous savez on
parle de haute qualité basses calories
balle à ce sont les belles calories et
je les calories très cher alors vous
allez voir d'abord de louis féraud dont
la tendance s'appelle grand nord
voyez ça c'est un petit renard à pois
noirs et blancs avec une queue de bélie
croquettes ferro fait beaucoup de noir
et blanc alors non seulement le renard
est vert et blanc mais ce costume l'a
fait entièrement de triangle avec un
manteau sur un costume avec des revers
de pluie elle savait qu'on fera
énormément de cuir cet hiver de carven
la ligne birman une rente ailleurs
violine avec une toque comme ses petits
camarades
ceinturée
et un renard luffy est toujours de
carven et toujours virement
e
mon tour
avec de la traque aux verts
deux j'en vois qui est un nouveau
couturier qui nous vient de danemark qui
fait de la scénographie et déballer un
kimono de fourrure de comscore sur un
autre que le cuir sur un costume de
bière détruire et toujours des gens
droits
voilà madame gens voient toujours un
kimono de cuir brodé sur une combinaison
de cuir s'appelle le fantastique et le
co est menée monde une ligne renaissance
toujours la coque les petites manches
saturé de satin
ok
et plus là un beau un renard le veste
brodée de perles également le pantalon
consater l'api du choc alors se faire
belle aux danses russes mais ça fait un
peu finlandais un caban blanc tel rôle
et rossi au lapidus un autre bleu qui
s'appelle du racket
prenez deux filles avec une cagoule
l'horaire enfin de frédéric castel
christian dior superbe carte en retard
au rendez-vous velours vient beaucoup à
l'époque au sein et se montent on aura
cours cet avenir un [ __ ] laveur
toujours comme davy crockett
roth de tuiles volailles sont belles
voilà terminé pour aujourd'hui tout est
possible pour nos téléspectateurs que
tout ça se passait en direct devant la
porte de l'antenne de 15 rue cognacq-jay
voilà n'avons pas voulu les faire trop
souffrir ses 25 ans et leur faire
présenter ses montées fourrure à
l'intérieur de notre studio nous avons
donc décidé les laisser à la porte c'est
que tout à fait sympathique lui même
pense qu'on a tout de même l'impression
que c'est ces manteaux et sont plus on
s'est tenus sont assez longues très
longues très longues on rallonge
beaucoup on élargit beaucoup et avec les
les époques de rigueur la mode toujours
s'efforce de dépenser beaucoup d'argent
en tissu en fourrure il paraît que c'est
un phénomène sociologique connu ça
permet de faire tourner les usines qui
fabriquent des tissus voilà quelques
centimètres de plus ces quelques mètres
de plus par entreprise